hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute war ich ein türkisches dessert und
zwar geht hellwach helmes ist so eine
masse also da gibt zwei verschiedene
arten einmal macht man es aus grease und
einmal aufs meer das eine ist ein ewig
in hostert das machen wird heute und das
andere wäre und hellwache mutter und
weiß ist eine matte aus grease oder mehl
und die wir dann mit wissen sirup
aufgekocht und schmeckt wirklich super
lecker das einzig schwieriger an der
sache ist dass ich eigentlich schwierig
aber sie schafft zeitaufwendig wenn man
muss am herd stehen und schon eine
gewisse zeit rühren und man macht dieses
dass er zum beispiel an feiertagen zum
ramadan zum beispiel wie viel los zur
verlobungsfeier aber auch zum beispiel
zu beerdigungen oder an besonderen tagen
macht man es eigentlich ja und ich finde
es richtig lecker ich weiß nicht was ich
leckerer finde ob jetzt krieg oder mail
ich finde beides wirklich super aber
heute habe ich mich jetzt begriffs
entschieden
ich zeige euch mal kurz die zutaten aber
bei den zutaten ist es jetzt so bei den
türkischen rezepten meist dass man die
mengenangaben in gläsern mist weil
einfach viele haushalte nicht meine
waage haben
früher war es einfach amerikanische mit
caps genau ich finde es immer ziemlich
ungenau aber bei dem rezept ist es jetzt
nicht schlimm ich sage euch jetzt die
mengenangabe in gläsern aber auf dem
blog stets natürlich auch in gramm
ich brauch 80 gramm butter 20 gramm
sonnenblumenöl und halbes glas kerne
eineinhalb leser weiten weichweizen
gries ein glas milch ein glas wasser ein
glas zucker und etwas von relax trakt
ich gebe zuerst die butter in einen
großen topf und zwar solltet ihr jetzt
einen topf nehmen der nicht beschichtet
ist
denn die masse mit gleich ziemlich heiß
und wenn sie dann später mit dem sirup
auch gekocht wird könnte es passieren
dass zum beispiel eine teflonpfanne oder
dem tv topf einfach auf platz es werden
da kommt jetzt bisschen öl mich dazu und
zwar deswegen damit die butter jetzt
nicht verbrennt wird jetzt erstmal
erhitzt
also zu stören damit die butter nicht an
genau das ist ja toll der schon mal
antritt
wenn hertha jetzt auch mittlere stufe
gestellt also ich hab jetzt auch fünf
von neun gestellt jetzt kommen da die
klinikkette mit rein und auch der gries
jetzt muss das ganze so lange geführt
werden bis der krise und die pinienkerne
farbe angenommen haben und es macht man
jetzt eben bei niedriger stufe und am
ende sieht es dann so aus wie so ein
nasser sand also von der farbe her und
es dauert ist ein wirklich etwas lange
und man muss halt immer wieder gut für
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
schon mal den sirup aufgehoben und zwar
nehme ich jetzt zucker und wasser ist
hier in einen topf und das ist kurz
aufkochen
so ist die farbe perfekt und zwar sieht
es jetzt aus wie nasser sand die
pinienkerne haben auch farbe bekommen
sind braun geworden und ich habe hier in
einem extra topf bereits die milch
aufkochen lassen und wieder die hitze
abgestellt jetzt kommt der sirup mit
rein das jetzt noch warm
jetzt müsst ihr wirklich sehr sehr
aufpassen denn diese krieges mars ist
wirklich furchtbar heiß
am besten nehmen sie den löffel raus die
hitze habe ich jetzt auch noch mal
runter gestellt auf stufe drei und
haltet den deckel vielleicht noch bereit
falls es wirklich spritzen sollte dass
ihr gleich abdecken könnte was jetzt
kommt direkt der einspritz zum glück
nicht langsam hoch stellen auf 5 früher
kurz durch aber wenn man sich daran
verbrennen das ist ganz ganz schlimm da
kommt auch die mädels mit rein
lass ich das ganze kurz bei stufe 5 auf
kochen
und gebe auch jetzt noch mal extrakt mit
dazu einfach nach geschmack so etwa
einen halben teelöffel
sobald es kommt kann ich den deckel
drauf setzen und das ganze bei stufe 2
also wirklich bei ganz geringe stufe
noch ziehen lassen bis die feuchtigkeit
komplett vom krieg aufgezogen
es dauert noch fünf bis zehn minuten
jetzt ist das helfer bereiten ihr
michael wasser hat können jetzt auch
sagen weil ich schwäbisch hall wird also
von der konsistenz sollte es trocken
aussehen
ich habe vorher auch schon mal den
deckel hoch genommen da war es noch sehr
grießbrei artig aber so sollte es jetzt
aussehen vor allem riecht auch wirklich
sehr gut und ich bin echt gespannt aufs
de moura schmeckt was ich mag sehr gerne
wer nicht so gerne zu süßes mag kann
gern den zucker whistler reduzieren aber
das ist halt was türkisches ist man hat
auch zu hause schon reduziert ja ich
hab's ja schon reduziert und auch sehr
gefiel das in ordnung zu günstig mehr
pinienkerne war für dich er doch er
wurde jetzt nämlich 1 1 nation er denn
damit kann man auch wunderbare kleine
kugeln portionieren abstechen
man kann jetzt warm oder kalt essen und
setze ich die hier auf einen teller
sieht aus wie kleine eisvogel genau
oder man kann zum beispiel auch ein
gefäß nehmen so ein kleines zahl kann
ich auch gleich zeigen und damit auch
das ganze umstülpen auf dem teller macht
jetzt drei so bändchen
jetzt ist es noch warm ist es warm oder
kalt
das ist eine rechtlich korrekt in der
türkei ist mir glaube ich zwei stunden
im speziellen ist noch heiß
es hat schon bislang aber aber das jetzt
waren zu einem kalten eis war richtig
cool oder macht es ist es war und dann
wahllos alles drüber
also in der türkei gibt es dieses mal
abstand und muss erkennen dass da würde
ich echt mal gern sehen wie man das
herstellt ich glaube das wird aus
ziegenmilch gemacht kann sein
ziege oder schaf glaube gewalt auf dem
fall keine kommen und das ist richtig
lecker das ist ein ice ist man mit
messer und gabel zum beispiel weil es
einfach so fest ist und man kann es halt
von der als wache lassen
pfizer hammer bestimmt macht er das
jetzt gleich noch mit bisher 1 also
falls ihr dieses rezept nach machen
wollt geht auf 6 - block data stets für
euch ich bin gerade wirklich total
überrascht dass der murat ist und es
auch mag
und es freut mich wirklich sehr
natürlich sah in deiner kinder gab es
ist und es erwartet hat gut geschmeckt
natürlich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen und mit denen uns das
nächste mal bis dann absolut lecker